[Music]
well thank you I'm Jonathan Carmel I'm a
product manager for Android in synapse
and you've come to the session for an
introduction to in synapse so I'm a
really excited to highlight a lot of the
partners that we have live today many
are in the audience but before we dive
into that let's talk about the
foundation of in synapse which are
Android apps we love Android apps
Android apps are getting better and
better they are fast seamless beautiful
and take advantage of device
capabilities let's take a look at some
of them on my home screen today we have
Ticketmaster who has a beautiful
end-to-end experience so let's say I
wanted to go see LCD Soundsystem well I
would just go into Ticketmaster out
search for LCD Soundsystem and do two
NDK support and in their seat view I can
find the exact seat I want see what it
looks like in the venue and by right
there next day I can actually get into
the concert with my phone then you have
citymapper
which has saved me a lot this week
because I'm actually staying in a
Mountain View hotel and I'm riding my
bike because I didn't want to hit the
traffic you all hit it's a 30-minute
bike ride and I have no idea how to
navigate the back woods of Mountain View
so I open up citymapper tells me the
exact transit and do the map view
support I can dive in and figure out
that turn that I just missed and go back
a few miles then you have Red Bull TV a
Leanback experience for immersive
television all of these add up to great
Android apps all of you in the crowd
have done an amazing job developing apps
but you told us in order to get that
experience you first have to install and
there's a friction point and you don't
have as many users using your best
experience so what if we can have that
same experience but what just with a
click you dive into it and that is
Android in synapse
they are native Android apps that run
instantly without installation so let me
dive into a very simple example I have a
friend Joyce and she loves bugs feed
she's on buds the BuzzFeed app all the
time just looking through videos the
other day she told me that there are
seven ways to make chicken wings now you
and I know all know that there are only
six ways to make chicken wings so I
usually would have to download the
BuzzFeed video app from the Play Store
wait open it up and then search for the
video she's talking about but now all I
have to do she sends me a link all I
have to do is click I dive right into
the native app experience and
unfortunately I find out there are
actually seven ways to make chicken
wings now I might not want to use
BuzzFeed I just want that experience
right then and there I don't necessarily
want to save it to my phone and within
apps you don't necessarily have to so
let's talk about a few of our additional
life partners today that I'm really
excited to talk about the first one is
dot loop which is a contract signing app
if you I don't assign contracts every
day but when I get that email that says
time-sensitive you have to sign this
contract right now and I'm in transit I
don't want to have to wait to get back
to my desktop to sign don't worry dot
loop has you covered
they have this beautiful native app
experience that really guides you
through the flow telling you how many
signatures you have to have in the
contract having you read flip through
the contract and then dive into the
exact place you have to sign now early
results for doubt loop have been
phenomenal they're seeing more users
start that experience there's double
digit uplift for just starting that
experience because they're guiding you
immediately and then they're seeing
double-digit increase for the number of
signed contracts hopheads
is another internet that's live and it's
a real estate browsing app now my wife
and I are looking to move right now or
at least I believe so because she keeps
on sending me links every day about new
properties so I don't have the hop ads
app on my phone but she
us because she's browsing properties all
the time but now when she sends me a
link I dive into this high fidelity
experience going to flip through all the
photos look at the dimensions of that
home look at a lot of rich textual
information like what schools are nearby
and then I can flip through new houses
that I'm interested in and when I'm
ready I actually can contact the broker
and set up time to actually see the
house
and that's exactly what hopheads is
trying to optimize for they want you to
reach out to the broker and actually see
the house and hot pads told us that
they've been optimizing their app for
over 12 years and to see the uplift
they're seeing right now is significant
let's talk about my new daily ritual
morning ritual which is New York Times
crossword I wake up in the morning I do
a quick search to find a New York Times
crossword I open it up in Google comm
and it shows a little instant badge
right next to it I dive into the instant
app experience and I get to finish the
crossword immediately and every day I
sign I send my best time to my whole
team for this is the time to beat for
the day now early data shows that I'm
not alone that this has become more
habitual for users in the internet they
are coming back more and more and
they're seeing significant increases in
reengagement from early data I'm very
excited to put this slide up today we
have 50 partners live so I want to thank
you all the partners that have worked so
hard to get these in synapse live today
so please give them a round of applause
we have 15 in synapse from 14 different
countries and you can see we cover a
bunch of different categories and I'll
just go through a few of them I'm sorry
I'm leaving some of you out but you can
see e-commerce partners like Jett wish
and Ticketmaster you can see
entertainment like Vimeo redbull Vicki
tabpro and New York Times crossword tap
row is great if you ever want to learn
guitar the of news and publishing apps
like CBC one football and pocket and you
have travel apps like TripIt Skyscanner
and city member over the last year these
partners have been extensions of our
product team they're not only trying to
optimize their instant app but they're
also giving us tons of feedback on the
platform and the tooling that we have in
place so a lot of the tooling that
you'll check out today is due to all the
hours of feedback they provided for us
so I really want to thank them again and
today at 4:30 p.m. 4:30 p.m. you'll see
a panel where you hear from the
developers themselves now let's take all
these apps and put them on our phone
that is a lot even the apps today that
is a lot of apps to fit on your phone
but thankfully these are native these
native apps are now part of your phone
you can access them anytime anywhere
even if it's not installed on your phone
now yesterday you heard that anyone can
now build an instant app so we're really
excited to open up to all of you and
start seeing more and more of you
develop in synapse you can now access
the documentation that download the SDK
and download the tooling so what should
you expect when you start developing an
internet one code base one project and
the tools you are already familiar with
you will develop in Android 3.0 the
first step you'll do is begin to
modularize your app and start taking the
features that you already have today and
breaking it up into different feature
modules and we have the tooling to help
you do that and lead you along the way
and we stress the reuse of code from the
installable app so you're again working
in one codebase one project when you're
on you upload to the play console now
you will not have to go and hire an
Android in synapse engineer this is the
Android development you are already
familiar with and when we've talked to
our 50 partners and asked them how long
did it take them to develop an instant
app all apps vary but they said on
average is about 4 to 6 weeks so let's
talk about how you prepare your use case
one thing I'll stress throughout this
presentation is the importance of
focusing on the action you're trying to
get the users to do so I know many of
you are focused on installations but
really what you're trying to do when you
develop your Android app and your intern
app is get the user to read an article
watch a video sign a contract do a
purchase get highly engaged in your app
that is your goal so what are some of
the motivations that we've seen and
heard from from our early partners about
why they developed an intern app will
break them into three categories the
first one is about focusing on your
current user base and optimizing their
experience and that that's what we call
conversion the second one is thinking
about new users that you can now reach
and the third one is completely new use
cases so again for conversion we think
about your current users and we're
thinking when we say conversion we mean
what metric are you really trying to
optimize so for your current users many
of you have told me that your native app
is one of your best properties and you
want more users going to your native app
so of your current user base you're
actually opening up accessibility of
your current user base to actually dive
into that native app so we launched
recently with jet and they're seeing
great numbers of the likelihood of a
user now purchasing when they land on
the instant app has increased
significantly by double-digits Reach is
about top of the funnel reaching more
users that haven't even seen your
property before this is true for a lot
of app first developers so you can
imagine for a lot of app first
developers they're thinking I
most of my discovery happens on the Play
Store I'm thinking about I'm getting
most of my users from installed users
and the question is can can we expand
that surface area can we reach new users
that you haven't reached in the past and
if you're thinking about now URLs is a
way to onboard into your experience
you're basically increasing that surface
area across the internet for new users
to actually interface with your native
app experience we see this especially
with cashbox they the podcasts for a
podcast oftentimes I listen to it
actually every day I listen to a podcast
and I love cat spots and well I I don't
always want to share my podcasts with
people because I'm not sure if they
listen to podcast and I don't know what
their experience is going to look like
but now when I share a URL I know that
they're going to dive right into that
same native act experience that I'm
experiencing and I know that's a great
experience
so my propensity to share has increased
finally there are new use cases that
we're excited to see what what the
people in this room start to think about
and develop now that there's no install
friction and there's not as much
friction between the physical and
digital world so you can imagine when
you go to a baseball game a museum and
you want to map for the day you're not
likely to install an app or if you go to
the baseball game and you have an option
to order food to your seat but you're
like I don't want to install an app I'm
just going to go to the concession stand
we've removed a lot of that friction so
there are opportunities to onboard users
and we're thinking here
things like QR codes beacons NFC new
ways to get the user into your
experience and we've been calling these
companion apps and we're really excited
to see what you guys all develop in this
room if you go to our sandbox today
you'll actually see some of these of
some of our early partners actually
developing these types of experiences so
at this point I'll hopefully are now
excited and motivated to start
developing an instant app so what should
you start thinking about alongside the
development what are the guiding
principles that will help you develop an
instant app there are five guiding
principles the first
one is the idea of one app we like to
think of in synapse and installed
installed apps as one app that run in
two different modes I often like to
compare in synapse to the streaming
version of music you're breaking up the
albums into songs and then streaming
each song it's very similar to what
you'll do within steps when you're on
the plane you download music to your
phone so you have offline access but
when you're sitting at home you don't
think about what music do I have on my
phone today you're actually just
accessing all the music that you have
you have access to and you're not
thinking I'll have to download this or
not so going back to one the one app
concept we want to think of in synapse
is the same app only being used on
demand from an engineering standpoint
that's exactly what it will feel like
again one code base one project all the
features you already use your installed
app in your internet in android 3.0
Android studio 3.0 we ensure just that
with high code reuse between your
installed app in your internet now again
we'll go in-depth and into the actual
development of an instan app at our
technical session later at 3:30 p.m.
which I encourage you all to go to and
there will actually develop an instant
app alive in less than 40 minutes but as
you can see here just from this diagram
all the features from your installed
apps are now present in your internet
and all that you've done is broken them
up so that now you Valley user can
access feature one module with not not
necessarily having to download and
install feature two module but from an
installed app standpoint it's the same
app it's the same output and so it's the
same experience from an installed app
nothing's changed from the user
standpoint you're thinking about the
same UI navigation and flows a lot of
developers ask me should I just develop
a trial app that is not the goal you
should not be thinking of developing a
trial Internet drawing back on the music
analogy ideally the user doesn't know if
they're in an instant app or installed
app because the content is the same
all those rich
experiences and all those great features
that you have your installed up you want
to pull over to your internet and it's
really important because if the user
ever goes from your instant app to your
installed app you want as little
relearning as possible there's no
onboarding process the user already
knows what this app does and they
understand all your features and we've
received a lot of positive data for
Vimeo which I think has done a great job
they pulled all their features into
their instant app and they're seeing
that Yelp users coming to their
experience they just they stay longer
they go deeper and to get more engaged
and so they've also seen double-digit
increase in engagement the next three
sections I'll talk about what happens
once you're in an instant app so let's
enter the app before you might have
thought of having one flow because
you're downloading let's say a
monolithic app and there's only one flow
that the user can go through that's now
changed within synapse you've actually
now think about side entry points into
your instant app so you have to think
about what that flow feels like if
someone just sends me in URL and I don't
know exactly what the in snap is going
to be and I click it if I hit a signup
flow I'm like I might be surprised I
might not understand why what the actual
value proposition yet is for that app so
you want to think of where across the
internet a user could actually enter the
app through tax social media ads all
these different mechanisms that a user
can come in and what is the context when
they actually click that app and you
want to account for that when you're
thinking about the flow if someone sends
me a recipe I want to drop into that
recipe if someone sends me a video I
want to drop into the exact video search
integration is also present in synapse
so you want to think about what happens
when a user lands into your page from
the search here I actually did a search
of my hometown in Franklin Michigan and
you see Zillow come up three times as an
intern app so what has dillos done they
said you're searching for this area
you're probably interested in the
property I'm going to make sure my
instant app dives you into
cific property on Sunset Drive and there
are three relevant properties for me I
click into that instant I click that
link and I dive right into the the
native app experience now side entry is
important but you're also going to have
to think about home entry so this was
shown at the developer keynote yesterday
of actually getting to use the in
Android
integration with launcher allows you to
launch instant apps from the home screen
so here you can see I typed in NY it
gives me a recommendation of New York
Times crossword instant app I click that
actually I pull that onto my home screen
and now when I click it it actually
dives me into the home screen of the
crossword puzzle it doesn't dive me
directly into the crossword puzzle
because it's thinking about the context
of the user and I'm driving into the
home screen of that native app so
oftentimes when we think about in
synapse we think about install friction
but there's friction that we're trying
to solve within synapse across the
native app experience we want to remove
all friction points that we've heard
from developers so sign-in is one where
I mentioned it and a few slides ago
where sometimes you're asked to sign in
when you have no idea what the app is
about other times with purchasing you
might not have a credit card around and
and yet you still want to purchase how
can we remove those friction points from
apps so as I mentioned before sign-in
sometimes happens upfront with
monolithic or with installable apps
because you've already gone through an
friction point you know exactly the user
flow the users going through so you
decide to have them sign in up front but
when users are coming through the side
entry you might not want a sign-in to
happen right then so we've actually had
a number of our partners who in their
installed app had mandatory sign in up
front had removed that and decided to
put sign in at a point in the flow where
they felt that the user understood why
they would be signing in and the value
of signing in
in synapse also uses smart lock for
Android which allows you to be continued
to be signed in between Android Chrome
and desktop sorry Chrome and Chromebooks
as well as being continued to be signed
in between instant app sessions for
purchasing there's visit others digital
purchasing and physical purchasing
digital purchasing is very similar to
what you experience or it's identical to
what you experience and installed out
there's in app billing that you'll
continue to use within synapse for
physical purchases we're actually really
excited to talk about Google payment API
some of you may have already heard about
it in the developer keynote where
assistant mentioned it and there is also
another session specifically talking
about the Google a payment API we're
really excited to have this as part of
in synapse so there are hundreds of
millions of cards that Google already
has on file and when you're thinking
about a user now entering a instant app
a lot of times there are new users they
might not have a form of payment or a
credit card on file with you yet but
they will they potentially have a form
of payment on file with Google now they
can access that Google Peyman API and
access that credit card you see here you
see that jet is using this Google
payment API and I just click pay and the
Google payment API or the Google pay
shows up it already has my credit card
information it already has my shipping
information with just a few clicks I'm
already done with my purchase so when I
mentioned before the jet is seeing an
increase propensity for users to
purchase when they landed the instant
app and they're seeing these great
numbers what I'm wondering is how much
of that is from the decreasing install
friction and how much is it from
decreases in the payment friction and as
we get more and more data I'm really
excited to parse that out and really
understand where how much value is
coming from each but right now as jet
has told us they're seeing significant
increase in purchases I also want to say
mention that we don't want you adding
additional friction points and with our
partner early partners we did a lot of
testing we try different stuff out and
we realized that
the thing we want to do is get the user
to that action that they came to do as
quickly as possible some early partners
tried splash screens others tried a lot
of installation problems and we just
think getting rid of all of these
friction points allows for a very smooth
experience so the user has had this
great experience in your instant app
they've really enjoyed it and now they
want to install for a number of reasons
maybe they want to do offline usage that
is fine we actually encourage
installation in that case so let's talk
about what that experience looks like
when a user chooses to install their -
first of all we've actually decreased
the friction point of installing in the
instant app there's this new API play
install API that allows you to install
inline when you're in an intern app so
in this case I'm playing a Red Bull
video watching some BMXer and I think
this video is awesome and I really want
to have this for offline usage so I
installed there and it allows me to
install online without having to go to
the Play Store what you also want to
take into account is copying that user
information from the Internet to the
installed apps so you know what they're
in this case their video history was and
you can actually put them right back
into the video they were watching when
they hit open installed out now let's
talk about the ways that you can
actually prompt a user to install there
are two ways the first one is explicit
installations this means that the user
knows that they're about to install if
they hit that button because it says
install the second one is implicit
installations these are when you click a
button in the Internet and the feature
might not be available like offline
viewing
so you prompt the user if you'd like to
use this feature please install so let's
talk about both tools that we have for
driving installation the first one as I
mentioned it - the explicit installation
you include the install you can install
string and the install install icon here
that you can see the amber weather did a
great job with and they embed it in
their UI what is amber weather thinking
well they want the user to get the
information they came for which is the
weather they want to show all these
great things that they have within their
app but now if the user wants to
the button is right there but it feels
really part of their UI which does a
great job of including in their
navigation drawer it's not disruptive
and it's very easy for the user if they
want to install to install right there
implicit installations as I mentioned is
when you click a button in the instant
app and that feature is not yet
available
Vimeo for example has offline viewing
and youngly has some personalized
information of personalized things what
they do they would only like and
installed out that's great that's fine
so here you see that the it prompts the
user to install and it gives context to
why the user has to install again early
partners have tried both explicit and
implicit installations we just encourage
you not to make it disruptive and for
the user to really know what to be able
to do the action they came to do and if
they choose to continue and potentially
want to install that you give them an
option to do so so you've built this
amazing app this amazing intern app that
mirrors your installed app you have
thought about all the different entry
points and the different flows that are
important to account for and you've
thought about decreasing friction from
identity to payments to installation so
now you're ready to track your success
what does that look like well first you
need to upload your intern app to the
Play console this is going to feel very
similar to your installed app we have
three different tracks there's the
development track the pre-release track
and the prod track and this allows you
to do some testing upfront and make sure
that you're ready for production also
the latest update that you push will go
directly to to who your users will serve
it directly to the user so if they click
that URL you get that updated Internet
we're also big proponents of
experimentation so we included something
called the mobile hold back and we love
this idea this allows you to hold back a
percentage of your traffic to go to the
mobile web so if I put in point to point
to 20% of your traffic will go to the
mobile web and 80% of your traffic will
go to in snaps this enables you to do
testing and experimentation we know that
you've optimized for years and years
your native app experience you've
optimized your mode
web site and you've optimized your
desktop and we want to make sure we give
you the tools to now optimize in snaps
and try to make it the best property
that you can so let's talk about now
what type of metrics you'll now be
tracking in the instant app that might
be different than how you thought about
with installed apps so I've showed two
flows up here one is where you start in
an installed app with the Play Store you
install your app you then signup you
then browse and engage with the content
of the native app and then potentially
purchase for instance a few of these
start to flip around first you're
entering the instant app from a URL
you're then can immediately engage
without ever without signing up and you
actually can purchase without signing up
in e-commerce for the e-commerce
category and you moat won't necessarily
install so you have to start thinking
about what are different metrics that
you now track that are important in in
snaps first you probably want to
separate installed apps and in snaps
when you're tracking just to see
different behavior maybe a user who's a
first visitor for your installed app
acts differently for your first visit
for your internet and that's because
you're actually creating different flows
the user might be coming through a side
door so that user in that context might
act differently you also might now think
about signed in users versus non signed
in users so from some of our partners
only had signed in users before and now
that they pull that out or moved it to a
different point in their internet
they're going to have non signed in
users you also have to think about URL
traffic sources which you might not have
considered in the past now Google
Analytics for firebase has you covered
we've worked for months with Google
Google Analytics for firebase to make
sure that all these metrics start to be
tracked for your instant app they are
continuing to work with us to put
additional tracking and think through
different additional complex metrics
that make sense in Internet's for our
early partners a lot of them have
actually used their current analytics
SDK so now that we're opening
documentation today we were excited to
talk to more analytics providers and
start thinking about more metrics that
we need to start including in the SDK
so with all the these partners have
shared with me I've noticed actually a
shift when they first started within
synapse they often talk to me about
installation and there has been a shift
in our conversation where we talk a lot
more about engagement because as I
showed in the flow before we used to be
that in order to see your success
metrics you'd have to install first so
an installation became a proxy for
success but we've kind of flipped it
around and now developers are saying how
do i optimize the tickets purchase how
do i optimize the flights found
how about watch hours and how about time
spent reading football articles so all
this has changed a bit and we're excited
to see how the how you guys start
thinking about metrics in a different
way so let's recap first I talked
through that anyone can now build an
internet so you can go to geo and slash
in synapse and download the SDK and view
the documentation secondly I talked
about what the big motivation is for
partners developing an instan app it's
thinking about your current users
thinking about new users and thinking
about completely new use cases the third
thing I talked about is what she keep in
mind as guiding principles as you in
parallel do development talk about one
app different entry points decreasing
friction from identity to payments
through installation as well as the new
metrics there are two talks that I'd
really encourage you to go to today the
first one is at 3:30 with shobhona and
honor Ruud will be actually taking you
through it live in synaptic in 40
minutes so it's really exciting and I
really encourage you to learn how
they're actually going to take an
installed app and turn it into an
Internet also I've done my best to
channel the developer voice from talking
to all our early partners but it's much
better to hear directly from our our
partners so I encourage you to go to
maru's talk who's the lead lead dbora
developer relations manager for
internets and she'll talk I have on the
panel chat box
Vimeo deliver ooh Zillow and periscope
and they'll talk about their experience
and you'll learn best practices so thank
you everyone
I'm so glad you
all came I'm happy to take any questions
from you now and also please visit us in
sandbox don't see and I'll be there also
to answer additional questions after the
talk thank you
[Music]